hi everyone
my name is avi i work at optimize head
of data science and i want to talk to
you about classifying documents using
gns graph neural networks
in this talk i'm going to talk about
how graph neural networks work it's a
very heavy topic don't expect to to come
out an expert but i do hope to give you
some sense of how it works and why it's
worthwhile
and how to pursue this
um
it's a bit of myself i'm father of two
most of the time
uh they get along especially if there
are snails around
and
the like dancing is to have shorter hair
so why graphs um
we
know a lot about how to deal with data
points individually but in real life uh
our data points they want to say
something about or predict something
have connections between them they have
relations that we need to address and if
we use this this data we can perform
better uh predictions on our data and
understand it better and analyze it
better
so just a few examples of how real work
data real world data is represented
naturally is graph
so we all know the social networks it's
a very heavy topic heavily researched
heavily used by most of us
and naturally there are other networks
that we know from life from our lives
computer networks train networks all of
them are networks you have uh stations
connected
uh knowledge graphs are a certain type
of uh graph where we use to represent
our knowledge of the world in a
structured way uh and even code and
molecules can represent it as graphs
of various sizes
so
the outline of the talk i'm going to
talk a little bit about graph machine
learning tasks and examples of how
these tasks were solved efficiently and
uh gave great expressive power using uh
graphs
in the recent
decade
um i'll talk a little bit about message
passing on graphs this is the classical
work but it serves as a basis for graph
neural networks which are generally an
extension of message passing and if time
allows i'll talk about how
we did a small plc on our data and we
hope to expand it later
at optimize
so typically we can um group tests of
graph machine learning into several
types the first being the node level we
want to say something about the node
level whether a node is an outlier or
maybe it's uh
of a certain
category so it's just a classification
task
or an anomaly detection class
on a specific node the second type
is the edge level where typically we
want to say whether an edge
between two nodes should exist or not
and we'll see an example of that later
another type of test is for graph level
prediction so if we talked about we
we've seen that there that molecules can
be represented as graphs so sometimes
you want to take statistics something of
the graph as a whole not just parts of
it for example i want to say something
about a molecule um
and some tests relate to sub graphs
so some of it is we need to say
something about a particular set subset
of nodes or edges in the graph or we
want to find automatically find subsets
of the graph that connect heavily
together which is called community
detection
so let's look at some examples just to
please the eye
uh the first and foremost being uh how
to categorize papers this work done back
in 2016
and here we are given is the problem is
given a citation network a list of
papers
citing each other
and we have a bag of words for each
paper representing
um just you know the words the common
words in
uh that paper
some of the papers are tagged with their
specific category and our mission is to
find the paper categories for all
uh the papers in the data set
so if you want to present that as a
graph we would we would say we would
represent papers as nodes
and the edges would be the sightings so
there would be an edge between
uh node u and node v if paper you're
cited pay-per-v
and this also is using uh graphs this is
a very nice visualization of it
the different colors are of course
different categorizations
[Music]
another example is the recommender
system
and we map it to a link prediction test
on a graph so uh i guess all of you know
what what recommender systems do uh in
that sense um
they they
were giving user interactions with
certain items it can be movies it can be
merchandise
or music they listen to
and if we want if you want to and we are
giving their interactions of what they
have done what they have watched what
they have bought what they've been
interested in and we want to suggest new
things
to
improve their experience
with our system
in that case if we want to model its
graph
our nodes would be users and items so
you have two two types of nodes this is
called the bipartite graph because we
have two types of uh nodes and they only
interact
between the groups and no not inside
and the edges would be there would be an
edge between user and item if they have
interacted with it and our goal is to
recommend more stuff that the user would
want
and
so here's an example of how it was uh
solved using graphs and they compared it
to other methods so example i want to
suggest a pin on pinterest similar to
that one
so naturally uh
i want to
if i have a cake i want this i want to
see more cakes it makes sense but it has
no relation to
a shirt even though it has the same
color
so they've compared similar uh various
ways
of uh constructing similarity between
items the first relied only on visual so
as you can see we see here the sprouts
and we're giving different
um
recommendations that also have circles
inside because this is what the network
has detected if we look at the
annotations this is annotated as a
client and we see more plants
this method uses only the interactions
but their method uses the interaction
together with the visual representation
in order to contract
more um
powerful recommendations and
similarities and this is where the
expressive power of graph neural nets
which we're going to to discover uh next
uh it comes into play because you can at
one at one go take take advantage of the
attributes of specific nodes as well as
their relationship to other nodes
this is where the power comes from
another example from my own life um we
deal with access requests so for example
if we have bella is
a team lead and she has people reporting
to her
we want to and and and some people have
access to some sensitive data we want to
ask to be able to answer the question of
whether anna
should have access to the date or not
so this is sort of also a link
prediction task that we can use here
we have in this really simple solution
example we might have a very good
solution that you know most of the team
has access and as you have it too
uh but sometimes it gets more complex
last example
of graphical certification
we talked about uh we didn't talk about
it about the
[Music]
drug discovery
and we want to be able to you know
search for new drugs and we want to be
able to tell from the get-go even before
we we create
the the chemical or the molecules we
want to be able to predict whether it
has some way of answering or treating
the
disease or some symptoms that we want to
to treat without generating uh uh
major
uh side effects
and this is something that can be done
and is done using graph classification
where we take the whole graph
as the input and we want to output
whether uh for example here whether a
molecule can be conserved as an
antibiotic treatment but we also want it
to be for example
in water or maybe don't cause other side
effects such as you know
yeah
and the node here would be the atoms and
the edges would be the chemical bond
this is a very natural way of the of
representing the molecule
um
so now we're taking a sharp turn and i
want to talk about message passing
graphs it's very simple but it's again
it acts as a basis for how graph neural
nets work
so the very basic
example is label propagation suppose i
have labels on some of of the nodes in
my uh graph
and i want to be able to tell to say
something about the whole graph it's
like a semi supervised learning what we
do uh we iterate on the graph and in
each iteration
each node would pass its own state in
this case it's the label it would patch
it pass its own state as a message to
each other neighbors saying hey you
should be part of the blue group you
should be part of the red group
and each um
and and each node they need to turn
including the node that have emitted
their own messages they also receive
messages and they use some kind of logic
in order to update their own state for
the next iteration so in the simplest
form it would be a majority vote they
would just say oh okay most of the
people around me are are blue a lot of
people
and then the algorithm stops when it
converges or when it exits the limit
because sometimes you can't reach a
convergence
in some
[Music]
fatal cases
it's also used for community detection
where each node would initially have its
own label saying oh i i want to form a
community and then as we propagate
through this and iterate uh some
communities will be
annihilated we'll be left with a few um
communities
so the next step we want to do as i said
this is a very simple form a simple form
but it can also it can be generalized
and we want to see how we can generalize
it so for example
so one one form of generalization is
trying to think of it as each node
information holds its hidden state and
here we're you know we're diverging into
uh stuff that we know from deep learning
and each node has its hidden state
and the message it passes doesn't have
to be its own state it can be some sort
of a function on its state
and also a function on the
uh
incoming state
and also instead of married
majority-wise we can do different
aggregations and activation functions on
what have you and we can select whatever
function we want
and we can combine when we when we want
to update
uh
the state of the node we combine its own
state with its neighbors so for those of
you who like um
equations sometimes it's easier to see
in an equation
uh here aj is the message that is passed
from node
i to j
and it depends on the state of i the
state of j and some
properties of the edge
perhaps its own hidden state which can
also be updated in a very more general
way and uh f edge is chosen of a
function that takes all this input and
creates a message that passes for
example if we talk about h31 from node
three to node 1.
and then h1
tag is
the new state of edge i sorry
where we take the messages from all the
neighbors we take the existing state of
the node and we take the features of the
node
x x i and we use that to update the node
using some function that can also be
which is also general we need to to
account for when it's selected
no and here comes the the question of
how we select the functions and this is
where deep learning comes into place
because
um
in deep learning we have uh or
differentiable learning with three
pillars um
one is the data of course
the other is we want to define some
target function that we want to uh
achieve
to make our test work
and the second one and the third one is
the architecture and the framework
says that if you have the data and you
have the target you have a target an
architecture that you can use to update
its weights to back propagate on
starting with the with your loss
you will you will be able to uh
train this architecture and find a way
for it to
answer your question
better so the data uh on our case is a
graph the target can be whatever uh
targets and losses that we
know from other types of learning it
depends if we want to do node
classification that would be for example
um
the
regular
loss that we know for classification for
each node
and let's talk about the architecture a
little bit
so don't be alarmed uh we will go
through this
basically um
what we do
uh in graph neural networks is each
layer
of the architecture corresponds to one
iteration on the graph so if the layer
is uh
if the network is three layers deep we
would have messages three layers long
three hops long
for example this is uh this is an
example of a two layer uh
network and this is uh this is our graph
we can see that if we want to know what
the hidden state of a would be after two
iterations
we first look
at the messages the aggregation of
messages it received from its neighbors
so that would be b c and d and this is
what we see here
these are the hidden states of them in
the last iteration
these are the transformations
and um
and for them in turn we also want to uh
know their own state and the way this is
calculated is by using
um the aggregation and message passing
from their own neighbors for example b
it's neighbors are a and c
and we can see this here a and c are
being transformed
into messages uh
they're aggregated in some way and then
we update
the state of b
so this is how the graph structure looks
like from the point of view of the a
node and we have a
batch of networks each for each node we
have a different
uh topology of the network
but what's important to see here is that
the building blocks do
repeat themselves
the local architecture changes but
for example in the first layer the
transformation that each node that each
hidden state
goes through when generating the message
is the same
these are all the same these are same
functions or weights that have to be
learned
and this is how this is all connected
um
so as i said
a layer
in the neural networks corresponds to a
message passing iteration so for example
if the layer is if the network is deep
then each node would be affected
by um
nodes that are two layers two hops apart
from it including itself if it is
connected to it to itself and this is
called the receptive field
of
of the network and it's very important
to take this into consideration the same
way that we for those of you know for
example vision
it is important to take into account the
receptive field of vision network
and we have repeating blocks on each
layer and we can also stack again and
again we use the differentiable learning
here
we can set other types of networks for
pre-processing for example
to you to in order to generate the the
first hidden state in the first layer
of the a node
i can if if it was an image i can have a
cnn a conversion neural network for
vision that uh transform the image into
a light and representation of the image
and then in this way generate the hidden
the initial indian state and when i
train the model i can update these um
weights the weights of the image as well
in one go
cold and i'll talk a little bit about
the plc that we've done
at atomize and then i'll have time for
questions because i guess there will be
a lot because um
um so what we want to do is document
types of files um according to their
sensitivity because we want to protect
them in different ways we have financial
data
we have um
private information and each of those
should have different exposure to people
in in and inside and outside the
organization uh so we typically have
files that are very important to project
like like financial reports
which should only be visible to very
specific people in the regulation and on
the other hand we have maybe pictures of
people's pets which are uh welcome to be
shared across the organization even
outside of it
so for example we can have a rule where
if there's a file that is accessed by an
account and then the co it's probably
very important you want to uh limit the
accessibility of it
uh to other people in the organization
and we have many rules in our system to
accommodate for that but we want to have
something more general that could
capture um
the types of people
and
uh
learn
their
effect on the files and also the files
themselves and use the titles in order
to
make better predictions and perhaps
discovered stuff that we haven't seen
so we did a plc using gnns and we were
able to just go to to fetch for certain
clients six percent more
documents which we can later uh
use to better protect the clients uh the
challenges that we're facing and this is
important is that we have multiple types
of nodes and relationships and most of
the uh work
in the
literature you know is is is focused on
one type of uh
of nodes but maybe some some types of
relationships but again this is some
something that can be accommodated for
because you can use the types of nodes
and relationships as features of the
nodes and
um
and edges
and
and use an embedding layer
on them in order to
which can also be learned in the same
process again using differentiable
learning and and this is this is where
the power comes from uh the graph size
is also a problem
there are ways to address that by using
uh uh by dividing into the subgraphs and
[Music]
making them talk to each other and
deployment um mlap is a very hot topic
right now
uh in the industry across the industry
but
uh there's very little talk about how
you do it with graphs um
which is a challenge
okay just to summarize stuff that we've
gone through so graphics can represent
real-world data into in an intuitive way
it's really recommended to look at it
that way uh it's intuitive for us as
humans it's a bit easier for the
computer to understand but we have ways
to help them um
using relationships between objects
together with their attributes uh can
lead to powerful predictions and
what i wanted to uh convey is that graph
neural net neural networks uh are
uh
is a universal framework for message
passing on graphs it's just you know
it's just message passing generalized uh
in a way that helps you
capture the real uh important aspects of
your data
without specifying it explicitly just by
looking at the data um and where you
start there are great courses uh
courses uh the one from stanford uh is
great i took it there's also a course by
michael bronstein
uh which is really good i haven't taken
it but uh i've heard good stuff about it
and if you want to start coding just
look at the tutorials of the relevant
libraries out there you can google it
they're great i used two of them and it
was really easy to get started
so thanks a lot now it's time for
questions
um thanks for attending
yeah thank you avi uh we have a question
for you
the question is by stephen and the
question is regarding the results of the
poc six percent additional document
discovered compared to what baseline
yeah so the baseline was the heuristics
that i discovered
that i mentioned earlier and we're still
analyzing words but uh but um you know
the rule that i showed with the ceo and
accountant is not something that we've
written it's actually something that
we've discovered using network
uh which was really great for us we were
that you know it led us to believe that
we want to continue this field
and i hope to do it next month uh
thanks for the question
more questions from the chat maybe
uh what are the
relevant libraries for deals with crafts
deep learning for with crafts so
there are
four
relatively
popular
libraries for it
and
some of them are cross-platform and some
of them are um
specific to you know tensorflow or
pytorch uh i really like dgl
different library uh but there's also
python geometric 5g
the thing i like most about dgl is that
it's um
generic it it needs different back uh
backbones
um
you can use the amex even amex net and
also tensorflow and title but you can
google them you can see all four of them
i don't remember the names of the others
the one called spectral
uh
how do you deal with new categories
coming into the graph so um it's not
part of the talk and it's really not
something that it's uh tom nyof is
asking how do you deal with new
categories coming into the graph and um
the answer is that it's not um
i would deal with it in the same way
that i'd use the way that they do with
any learning task that i'm handed that's
that's that's the whole um
power
of putting this inside the
differentiable learning uh framework so
long as i have my own my target um
um
represented in in a clear way that that
serves my business purpose and
then i can do whatever it takes to
accommodate for changes in the data so
it's not different from regular learning
tasks whatever you see for it
can apply to graph learning and we can
talk about it later if you want on slack